Now we've talked a bit about how to
share your prototype with people who
might help you build it better.
One other very common kind of
presentation is a demo of your
prototype.
These demos come in all shapes and
sizes, from a 30-second elevator
pitch to a 2-hour presentation.
You'll want to spend some time thinking
about how to best talk about your
prototype and
show it to various audiences.
These presentations do have some
fundamentals you can start with.
Your elevator pitch can quickly explain
what your app does, who you do it for,
and why it is important.
You've already made an elevator pitch
if you've been through that course.
But it'd be a great idea to take some
time now to refine that elevator pitch.
After all, if you've properly adapted
your app using the marketing course,
it's likely that the who has changed
since you first made that pitch.
And if you've been prototyping well,
it's possible that the what
has changed as well.
Take a moment to revisit
your elevator pitch now, and
check the box when you're done.